good morning it gets Tuesday so today I
want to tell you an amazing story about
a monkey who was hanged for treason and
then many years later in a roundabout
way kind of became the leader of the
people who had executed him but first I
have to tell you how I learned this
story so my guys you know nerdfighteria
and I sponsor a fourth tier fan owned
English soccer club called AFC Wimbledon
where the back of short sponsor our logo
occupies that liminal space between
buttock and thigh and not to brag or
anything but AFC Wimbledon have won
three straight games including most
recently a to nil defeat of Hartlepool
so I was reading up on the game and I
came across an odd headline Hank Don's
down monkey hangers this led me to
Wikipedia and you know it usually when
you fall down a Wikipedia rabbit hole
nothing good comes from it but
occasionally monkey hangers so I'm
journey back with me if you will to the
early 19th century the French Revolution
which promised democracy and freedom and
equality has failed spectacularly as
revolutions often do and in the end all
they've done is replace a despot named
Louie with a despot named Napoleon to
celebrate his success within France
Napoleon Bonaparte decides to start a 13
year long conflict aptly known as the
Napoleonic Wars in which he conquers and
then eventually loses most of Europe
except of course he never conquers Great
Britain and he also never conquers
Russia because you cannot invade Russia
in the winter unless you're the Mongols
ok the story goes and sadly it is
probably just a story that during the
Napoleonic Wars a French warships sank
just off the coast of Hartlepool which I
should mention I guess is a city in the
northeast of England of course like a
lot of British place names Sunderland
snod land Braintree Hartlepool sounds
like a place where hobbits live but in
fact is a real city of like 93 thousand
citizens right so this French warship
sinks right off the coast and the only
survivor of the wreck is a monkey
wearing a French army uniform now the
good people apart the boat living as
they do in the far northeast of England
have never seen either a French person
or a monkey so they naturally assumed
that this monkey is a French spy an
impromptu trial is held on the beach the
monkey is found guilty of treason and
hanged
now what probably actually happened is
that an old folk song was adapted to
history but whatever the people of
Hartland braced this monkey hanging
business unreservedly
in fact hang since 1999 the mascot of
Hartlepool's football team has been a
monkey named
Hengist get it angus is an A
and then hang Gus is a pun on monkey
hanging but it gets weirder in 2002 the
guy inside the Hengist the monkey
costume was named Stuart Drummond and
mostly as a publicity stunt the team
supported Stuart Drummond's run for
mayor the only campaign promise he ever
made was free bananas for all
schoolchildren there were also lots of
real politicians running labour
conservative all this standard UK
parties but Stuart Angus the monkey one
and then despite never getting those
bananas to schoolchildren he was elected
again in 2005 and again in 2009 to
summarise take a city in England hug a
monkey who became a mascot who became
the mayor I guess there are really two
lessons in this for me Hank the first is
embrace your history even if it's
bananas time I made a pun and the second
lesson for me is that we are always in
the middle of history like heck imagine
that you're that monkey things could not
really have gone worse you're
conscripted into the French army you're
sent to sea which is not the ideal place
for monkeys to be you're forced to wear
this ridiculous French army outfit and
then to top it all off you're hung by a
bunch of heartless PUD Wiens if you're
that monkey you're probably thinking
this is about as bad as it could have
gone but there was this whole future the
monkey couldn't possibly have known
about as indeed there is a future that
all of us can't possibly know about and
in that future this monkey becomes a
weird symbol of the community that
hanged him and then gets its ass kicked
by AFC Wimbledon so I guess it is kind
of a sad story now that I think about it
we are in the middle of history and
there's something encouraging about that
to me I mean maybe we can make things
better for that monkey probably not at
this point but you know I don't know
I remain weirdly optimistic Hank I'll
see you on Friday